this is clay Jensen we dated we're so
happy for you clay you finally got the
girl and managed to escape prison at the
same time we knew you were innocent but
the fact that Ani lied for you truly
believes how much you mean to her we
can't wait to see you guys going study
in season 4 but unfortunately it seems
like Liberty High isn't done with murder
investigations just yet we just hope you
and Annie can have some good times
before the next scandal hits the fan in
this ending explain video will reveal
who killed Bryce Walker and why we'll
also go over the mini clues that were
dropped throughout the last episode they
seriously lay the foundation for season
4 so let's jump right in
we're survivors by the end of season 3
clay Jensen is finally cleared of murder
charges thanks to a nice statement the
police were hell-bent on charging him
with Bryce Walker's murder since he had
the most motive clays friends were
running out of time to prove his
innocence which prompted on his plan to
blame montgomery de la Cruz for Bryce's
murder but by the end of the season
finale we all know that Monte wasn't the
one who murdered Bryce in the end it was
revealed that Alex dandle was the one
who bashed Bryce into the water his
split decision to end Bryce's life
caught Jessica Davis by surprise but
that wasn't enough to stop her from
watching him drown
Jessica and Alex kept the incident to
themselves until they just couldn't and
thanks for their loyal friendship they
were able to escape a lifelong jail
sentence but why did clay in the gang
cover-up for Alex and will they live to
regret it
keep watching to find out
Alex and Jessica were able to walk free
thanks to Monty however he helped them
unwillingly from the grave after being
arrested for assaulting Tyler down Monty
met a gruesome fate in jail Bonnie came
up with a plan that allowed for the dead
to bury the dead and officer sandal ate
it up willingly comer Delacruz killed as
a result Monty was tagged with the
murder of Bryce Walker but while he was
guilty of many things murder wasn't one
of them after finding out that Monty had
passed away in jail on'y and clay came
up with a plan to keep Alex and Jessica
out of prison since Monty had no alibi
on the night of the riot it made sense
to pin Bryce's murder on him however
Monty did have an alibi instead of
pushing Bryce
off the dock and into the water he was
safely tucked in bed with Winston his
best kept secret pointing a finger at
Monty would have never been possible if
it hadn't been for Tyler who had the
biggest glow-up throughout the new
season with Jessica's help Tyler spoke
up about what happened between Monty and
himself which resulted in Monty being
taken to jail if Tyler had never found
the courage to speak up Monty wouldn't
have passed away and given the game.the
out they so desperately needed
but as Tyler grew stronger and stronger
Alex grew more feeble no amount of
steroids could have made alex strong
enough to face the truth he murdered
Bryce while he was helpless and hurt
Alex has always been a wild card and
he's always been rash and emotional as
the season finale got closer and closer
Alex began showing signs of extreme
depression once again this led him to
ask Tyler if he still had a gun which
isn't something that should be looked
over Alex was ready to confess to
Bryce's murder by the end of the season
and it sounds like he was ready to make
another attempt on his life
but while Alex might have gotten away
with murder it looks like he isn't out
of the water just yet Monty's secret
hookup Winston is
well aware that he didn't kill Brice and
he looked just about ready to spill the
beans when he confronted Ani in the
season finale what did you tell the cops
he didn't kill Brice
so it's safe to say that we haven't seen
the last of Winston but Winston isn't
the only one who knows that Monty
killing Brice just doesn't add up
alex is very own father officer
Standells seemed to have his doubts
about Anees confession he knew that his
wife's car had been at the scene of the
crime but he took the bait anyway we
later see him burning evidence in a
trash can proving that he knows that
alex is far from innocent but will
tampering with evidence come back to
haunt him in season four well that
remains to be seen what we do know
however is that clay and ani think that
Alex is worth saving even though he
pushed Bryce into the water and watched
him drown in the end Ani knew that if
Alex went down so would Jessica and
despite their actions they're both good
people Alex chose to kill Brice after
realizing that Brice would never change
but after hearing Bryce's confession
tapes Alex seems to have realized that
he made a big mistake clearly Alex isn't
doing okay which is why he might turn
out to be the antagonist of season four
after all with Brice and Monte gone a
new evil is bound to rise at the end of
season three we see a fisherman stumble
across Tyler's guns and since Ani told
officer stand all about Tyler's
attempted shooting he may be linked to
the firearms we also know that Winston
isn't going down without a fight and so
on easel a buret lie might start to fall
apart in season four do you think Alex
and Jessica should have gone to jail or
has justice been served
sound off in the comments and that's a
wrap thank you for watching the things
give this video a big thumbs up and
don't forget to subscribe to our Channel
we'll catch you later
[Music]